paul dirige un centro de rescate de aves
en ecuador una de cada diez rapaces
capturadas ilegalmente sobrevive es el
caso de gandalf un águila andina con
cinco años en cautiverio por daños
psicológicos no regresará a su entorno
porque corre el riesgo de morir pero
otras aves sí serán liberadas un
dictamen de la corte constitucional ha
reconocido el derecho de los animales
priorizando su reinserción natural que
tratemos a cada animal de mejor manera
para que no entre en estrés o depresión
y en la mayoría de casos claro tratar de
liberarlos de reinsertarlos nuevamente a
la naturaleza cinco mil animales son
rescatados al año en el país andino son
enviados a uno de los 50 centros de
rescate o zoológico se cree que se
agarre martín supervisa que sur o un oso
de anteojos reciba el trato más parecido
a su hábitat fue sacado de una casa
donde una familia lo tuvo como mascota
acostumbrado al cuidado del hombre
durante 20 años no podrá ser liberado a
pesar de la sentencia
cuando tienen condiciones físicas o
comportamental es que no lo permiten
pueden ser mantenidos bajo cuidado
humano bajo cuidado técnico profesional
como zoológicos que estén debidamente
acreditados la sentencia de la corte se
desprende luego que una mujer
interpusiera un recurso de protección en
contra del estado en el año 2019 porque
le puede comenzar un mono a la nudo en
peligro de extinción que mantuvo en
cautiverio durante 18 años
entretanto en el centro de aves el
trabajo ha sido arduo más de 400
especies han regresado a su hábitat
y muchas de esas con emisores
satelitales que está nos ayuda al
municipio de quito para saber dónde hay
mataderos ilegales de animales
un nuevo habitante y en el centro y
rescate es un felino abandonar para un
rechaza la comercialización de especies
silvestres y lo acoge en su nuevo hogar
ecuador es un país megadiverso donde 91
ecosistemas coexisten su riqueza está
basada en su diversidad natural gracias
a una sentencia la vida animal valdrá
tanto como la del hombre